hello
and welcome to our session covering
breakthrough insights across the life
sciences value chain
i'm kevin julian senior managing
director
in accenture's life sciences practice
and later i'll be joined by my colleague
mike stapleton
who's the head of strategy for
accenture's life sciences intent
platform
during this session we'll be talking
about why
creating breakthrough insights in life
sciences
is more important than ever and we'll
share how intia
accenture's life sciences platform
powered by google
is able to generate insights using
leading-edge google technology
during this session we'll spend most of
the time illustrating examples
of how insights are being generated by
indian across the life sciences value
chain
from early research through pivotal
clinical trials
all the way through to delivering care
to patients
our industry is at a turning point
shifting from small molecule
large population strategic approaches to
a more targeted scientific approach
this shift is powered by what we at
accenture call
new science new science is a novel
chemistry
or biology in previously unsolved areas
of need
like cell and gene therapy often enabled
by technology
to deliver the therapy or to support the
patient or sometimes
maybe technology itself an app or other
technology solution
that intervenes in an effective way to
improve the patient
why the shift something had to change
the old model simply was not supporting
the needs of the market
new science is attracting significantly
more attention and investment
and for good reason accenture research
has determined
that new science therapies are almost 50
percent more likely to be approved
and greater than 50 of sales over the
next several years
are expected from new science
this shift to new science brings the
industry's dependence
on technology to the fore increasingly
industry depends on connecting data
across the enterprise
to generate insights into how therapies
should be developed
and brought to patients while this
ambition is clear
it's also clear that industry has yet to
take the necessary actions needed to
achieve their goal
according to this idc study more than 50
percent
of respondents did not have a clear path
to connect
share and analyze information across
their organization
this is where ntn comes in
intian accenture's platform for the life
sciences industry
powered by google cloud enables insights
and collaboration
across the life sciences enterprise
indian helps the industry generate
breakthrough insights in three powerful
ways
through functionally oriented product
suites that have been built in key areas
of insight need
drug research clinical trials
pharmacovigilance and patient services
with other use cases enabled by the ntn
core platform
and through additional use cases enabled
by the intiant network
our open ecosystem access solution
through access to innovative specialty
software services
hardware content and other business
partners
the ntn network offers industry standard
apis
for pre-competitive functions that
easily and quickly integrate into
existing systems
the ability to rapidly and flexibly
deploy solutions
and lower barrier to entry for new small
and or niche software players
all of this is made possible by the
intune core platform powered by google
cloud
the core platform is a flexible and
powerful data centric solution
that connects a variety of data sources
and makes
insight generation possible how does it
do that
we start by using google's healthcare
api to accelerate solution development
and access third-party solutions with
fully managed enterprise scale
fire hl7 and dycom apis
we use google's bigquery to analyze
virtually unlimited amounts of data
using standard sql at scale with zero
operational overhead
and automl provides non-expert users
with access to pre-configured
high-quality machine learning laws
such as image detection translation and
natural language process
let's illustrate the power of india with
a few examples
to start my colleague mike stapleton
will share some of the exciting insights
our clients are generating
with ntn research bye
thank you kevin uh in the next section
of our presentation we're going to bring
the power of indian to life looking at
three critical parts of the
pharmaceutical value chain i'll start
with research
as kevin mentions i'll then go through
clinical trials and then hand back to
kevin
we'll take it home connecting the value
of research and development
to the patient and the impact we get out
on us and
society in general so let's start with
research
and the fundamental challenges that face
drug discovery scientists
whether discard starting with a disease
or starting with a target
or starting with a biomarker discovery
program
or indeed repurposing existing research
efforts
in every single case drug discovery
scientists are challenged
bringing together a wide range of
external data
lots of historic hard to retrieve
internal data
assembling that data bringing it
together in a format that can be easily
managed easily visualized and decisions
taken from that
aggregated data consistently
across the whole of drug discovery
research
that integration of data that thinking
through a single query
how easy it is to make a decision and
how we can embed advanced tools
artificial intelligence
machine learning so that more informed
decisions more informed predictions can
be made
to advance faster and in a more focused
way
to bring this to life i'm going to dig
into one of these in a bit more detail
and take a look at target discovery as a
particular example
to show the power of the ancient
platform
the key challenge here quite easy to
state is that
as an industry as a society we know
more and more about human disease
biology
than we've ever have done and we
continue to learn
more and more on a daily basis through
the advances
in genomics to the connectivity
and measurement of mobile devices that
we all wear today
we understand more and more about us as
patients
and how that information is connected to
a therapeutic
or a particular condition or a lifestyle
that we have as individuals
but even with that yet roughly 90
percent
of candidate drugs fail in the clinic
and a large number of those fail because
in early stage drug discovery
we still choose poor targets
this has the obvious consequences to the
industry
long development times increased cost
and quite significantly negative patient
outcomes
so if we had the opportunity as we do
with a platform strategy like indian
to address this key bottleneck this key
area of pharmaceutical r d we would
quite clearly have huge impact
so why is it so difficult let's have a
look at the operational consequences of
drug discovery today
very diverse skill sets are required to
manually
bring together that external and
internal data
integration of that data is extremely
time consuming
and often error probe key patterns
key indications key predictions can only
be made
through machine learning and artificial
intelligence capabilities
not by the human mind and so that's
where the ancient solution comes in
we can use the intiant solution to bring
in those broad
array of data sources we can aggregate
those data sources
filter pre-process and present the data
in a much more meaningful and accessible
way to a scientist
through dashboards alerts predictions
that allow scientists to better
prioritize
spread a guide and allow a portfolio
activity of project teams to better
manage assets
and to move forward through the drug
discovery process
ultimately identifying novel targets
and prioritizing targets which have a
much higher
probability of success further into
pharmaceutical development
let's take a look at a screenshot of how
that would actually look
and we see here a simple screenshot
of a modern user interface from indians
where we bring together that drill down
of both therapy genome
and target and that important interplay
for a drug discovery scientist
to make all of those connections through
a simple interface
to click to understand and to predict
and obviously underneath all of this
what is powering all of this what makes
all of this possible
is the incident beta fabric how we
actually
ingest those broad sources of data how
we present those
analytic viewpoints so that they are
useful
and guide in an intelligent way how is
support
as kevin mentioned the broad range of
both chemical and biological research
that now
is just part of the armory for a
pharmaceutical research scientist
and how ultimately we action how do we
actually
inform partner companies other
scientists colleagues across the globe
to do something as a consequence of our
insight through a very
integrated request management capability
so you can see at all levels here in
drug discovery
in pharmaceutical research how intian
how the platform that kevin described
addresses the key bottlenecks of
bringing together the data
aggregating the data and presenting it
in an actionable unpredictable fashion
success in research then takes us
forward into pharmaceutical development
so let's take a similar view of clinical
trials
and we start in a very similar way we
start with the complexity
of managing very large very diverse
sets of data both internal and external
to the pharmaceutical company
hundreds of patients across dozens of
sites globally
being monitored and tested and the data
from
all of those patients in my new detail
being brought together for future
analysis
prediction and regulatory filing hugely
complex logistics
that require a scale of computation to
cleanse
process and integrate that data across
broad ranges of genetics genomics
mobile data real world data
so that ultimately we can create
insights
presenting that aggregated data
in real time so that prediction can be
made an analysis made
to actually guide future trial design
to inform uh conduct and commercial
viability
and to ultimately facilitate the filing
of a new drug to the regulatory
authorities
let's take a look at clinical operations
as one example here
of how all this comes together the
challenge being as i just stated
bringing together those very large
diverse formats and sources of data
from numerous internal systems across a
pharmaceutical company
and significant sources of information
from partner cros and this leads this
challenge leads to inconsistency
leads to delays in actually changing
trial guidelines and ultimately
increases costs and time
so what makes operations in clinical
difference as
we ask the question in research a few
moments ago again we still
see similar patterns here integration of
those disparate data sources
is fundamental extremely time consuming
and extremely expensive effective
monitoring requires
access to comprehensive and timely data
and trends in clinical trials are
complex and require incredibly
complex interactive analyses so again we
see how the intian solution the platform
capabilities
addressing these complexities and
challenges
facing clinical operations
robust flexible data ingestion
transformation that data in a way that
makes the data usable
and actionable actions to actually
remediate
issues in a much more timely fashion
and visualizations through interactive
dashboards predictive tools
predictive simulation and analytics
methods
so again if we go to look at a
screenshot here
we can see how all this comes together a
single viewpoint
a clinical control tower if you like a
visualization of the state
of a particular trial or a set of trials
how we monitor these through that
dashboard how we see
uh red amber and yellow uh indicators to
easily flag
activities that are on track or are not
on track and require
action how we can drill down into
problematic areas
regions countries sites and particular
patient demographics and how those
reports
can easily be accessed by all leadership
and scientists and medical practitioners
collaborating globally
on a particular program so with research
and clinical we've seen how the common
themes
of data integration aggregation and
presentation of that data
our analysis and visualization and
prediction of that data comes together
through intimate
and success then means we move to the
patient
and kevin will take it from here to
explain how the value of rmd
is then accelerated through greater
patient engagement
thanks mike and indeed
even if one were to identify
the best research target and
successfully take it through
clinical trials with all the
capabilities that mike just described
it wouldn't achieve its ultimate
potential
if we didn't solve for the needs of the
patient
we're targeting you ntm helps
life sciences organizations get closer
to the patient
through our intim patient solution
capabilities include integrating patient
care
which supports better treatment outcomes
real world outcomes research
creating greater understanding of
clinical and economic value
patient engagement support which
improves initiation and compliance
to prescribed treatments and precision
medicine delivery
which provides needle to needle support
for new treatment programs
all of those are important but let's
focus on integrated
patient care with india patient
we're unable to allow physicians to
prescribe
digital support programs allowing
patients to use devices and apps
and all connected by an indian patient
to manage their care
we allow their care providers to monitor
that care
analyze and make recommendations to
improve the care program
all this importantly enables us to lower
cost
improve patient adherence and ultimately
improve patient outcomes
let's take a look at an example of our
digital patient study solution
which provides a tool for principal
investigators to cohesively manage
virtual stadium performance
with ntn patient we can manage and track
patient enrollment across
sites easily configure
and provision the devices that patients
use
track adherence to protocols and make
early interventions
that prevent patient dropout from the
clinical trial
and language insights learned through
the trial
to ultimately create an even better
patient experience
when that therapy is brought to market
all of these capabilities together and
the insights
that are derived from them help our life
sciences customers
develop therapies that are built
and delivered with the patient in mind
those are the examples of insights that
we've generated across
the life sciences value chain using
anti-life sciences
accenture's life science platform
powered by google
if you have any questions our contact
information is on this slide
we'd be happy to answer them
now it's for me to thank you for joining
us to learn more
about generating breakthrough insights
across the life sciences value chain
thank you